it is your voice racer disco whoa the
new Mary Queen of Scots is worth seeing
for the accents alone you would do well
to watch or watch the Oscars favorite
stars Irish actress Saoirse Ronan as the
Scottish Queen Mary and Australian
actress Margot Robbie as England's Queen
Elizabeth did they sound historically
accurate how might have the actor's own
accents shaped their performances and
how exactly does one learn to do a
Scottish and English accent for answers
I went to Hollywood dialect coach Jack
Wallace he broke down the accents of
Mary and Elizabeth in the film and
taught me a few of his tricks at nailing
new accents my name is Caroline from
insider and today we're looking looking
and today we are looking at excellent
you would do well to watch or work I
will not be scolded by my inferior one
of the great things about this movie is
that there's this huge rivalry between
these two queens they say the same word
one after another and you can hear
they're said in very different ways my
inferior and then she responds directly
in foody area they have very different
tones very different ways of saying that
and that really just helps to heighten
the tension in general the way that
Scottish people use their arse is very
different they tap their arse for
example in inferior in fear the flicking
your tongue rather than say inferior or
inferior to the untrained ear a Scottish
accent might not sound too far off from
Sasha's own Irish broke and you motor
your Queen it turns out they're actually
pretty different phonetically true that
some Scottish accents and some Irish
accents have some shared sounds
thankfully first Saoirse in this film
her Dublin accent is very different from
the east
Scottish accent that she's portraying
when the movies trailer was first
released some history buffs were
confused at how Scottish Saoirse sounded
after all Mary was sent to France as a
child to marry the young French Prince
she stayed until she was 18 when the
Prince died she finally returned to her
homeland that's a good 13 years Mary
spent in the French Court
so wouldn't she speak English with a
French accent not a Scottish one it's
more likely that when she went initially
her French would have a slight Scottish
accent but it wouldn't affect where she
spoke English okay now what about Queen
Elizabeth for this role Margot Robbie
had to ditch her Aussie accent for an
English one holding on to an accent
that's not your own can be particularly
hard during highly emotional scenes
everyone does a great job but if I had
to nitpick there's just this one tiny
thing that happens in one of the clips
margot robbie is in the throne room
she's addressing her home court and as
the end of the speech she gets quite
emotional and she does this huge
movement at the same time and there's
this tiny tiny little vowel change that
happens because of it we could do what
better place her on the throne of
England she says we could do worse than
to place her on the throne of England
typically her and worse should have the
same bells um but if you listen again
here we could do what better place for
on the throne of England so placing her
go a little bit back towards her
Australian accent something very small
and I don't think anyone else related so
overall Saoirse and Margot did an
incredible job here but that's not to
say they speak exactly like the
historical figures they're playing plus
in movies the accents aren't always
supposed to be totally true to the time
period now you have the boldness to
doubt my judgement even 50 years ago in
England it would be boldness with a full
o sound before that l boldness she says
boldness and that's a much more modern
way of saying that and what that does in
the movie it helps to raise the distance
from the 1500s to 2018 the modern viewer
will see that and be kind of immersed in
that action rather than creating some
barrier all this talk about accents had
me excited to give it a try myself which
Queen are we gonna start with excellent
so you've got that fighting spirit I'm
noticing when you speak you have a nice
openness in the mouth we want to bring
that to a narrower place for a Scottish
instead of hello we want with your hand
try to make the shape of your tongue
when you do that though yeah do that
again
[Music]
not bad we're getting there so we're
gonna move on because if we keep
practicing or something then it yeah
it's too much in our brain and we get
again now for Queen Elizabeth hello my
name is Caroline from insider and today
we're looking at accents so it's in
those elves is where it's coming in and
this one insider we end in a vowel we
don't have an R that there's no R in
England so keep your face very nice and
neutral and go again hello my name is
Caroline from inside
[Music]
great yeah so I don't know if I got to
Saoirse and Margo's level of mastery but
I think I got pretty close
of course accents take time so it'll
take a little bit of practice before I
can totally nail my Queen Elizabeth
voice until then I'll be exclusively
watching period pieces and BBC
miniseries for inspiration
[Music]